[Music]
am I about to be auctioned off right now
we're just yeah my lutely are creepy
alright hey this is the reward for
winning okay wonderful
hi deny back here in the back where you
asked I want to know how it feels to be
a part of one of the most memorable
times for black film oh my god
it's it's a Renaissance this this is you
know something that you know I I did I I
almost never became a director because
there's such a shortage of role models
we had spike we had John Singleton we
had the Peebles a--'s we had the Hughes
brothers but they felt like the
exception to the rule I'm so proud to be
a part of a time at the beginning of a
movement where you where where I feel
like the best films in every genre are
being brought to - to me by my fellow
black directors maryse Peschel and I
think that goes for all areas of
inclusion but it's quite clear with the
work that Ava's doing that Ryan's doing
F gary Gray berry that this is a very
special time we're going to 38 and then
to 123 okay
38 congratulations the Picture
Association of America
you mentioned the crew during your your
speech what do you what can you tell us
about the below-the-line crew
specifically on your film you know it
was it's such a scrappy group and I mean
scrappy you know we did that we made
this movie in 23 days four point five
million dollars I had people that I
shouldn't have been able to afford do
this movie because they believed in it
and they put their trust in my vision my
ad Gerard de Nardi and his team worked
miracles with the schedule we had and
what we had to accomplish my wardrobe
department
haters my costume designer worked
miracles with what she had to work with
Toby Oliver and his department worked
miracles rusty Smith this is an
independent film and we we sweated for
it so I'm I felt like I had the
privilege of being a pirate captain with
a swarthy group of real badasses and I
love them I'll never forget a single one
of them thank you going to 123 and then
61 okay hi Jordan there you are
shadownet to meet you as you continue to
move forward telling stories about race
and things that have affected us in our
society how important our Oscars and
other awards essential to you for
validation or to continue to move
forward well you know I I didn't know
how important this was I always wanted
this but the the campaign is grueling
and there are times where I I questioned
what is it all about your your your
watching your own your last jump shot
for a year and it does as an artist that
doesn't feel right it doesn't feel right
to be complacent and to feel like I've
done anything too special to reward
myself when the nominations for this
came together first of all when the
nominations came out I had this amazing
feeling of looking at the the 12 year
old that had this burning in my guts for
this type of validation and I it
instantly I instantly realized that an
award like this is much bigger than me
this is about paying it forward to the
young people who might not believe that
they could achieve the highest honor in
whatever craft they want to push forth
you're not a failure if you don't get
this but I almost didn't do it because I
didn't believe that there was a place
for me
Whoopi Goldberg and her acceptance
speech for Best Supporting Actress
for ghosts was a huge inspiration to me
and and when I got nominated one of the
first things I did was reach out and
call her and thank her for telling young
people who may be doubted themselves
that they can do it so I hope that this
does the same and inspires more people
to use their voices we're going to 61
and then I am being told to wrap up so
we'll end with number one right here
hi there Natalie here from Forbes this
mindset this might sound
counterintuitive but did having a small
budget give you freedom as a director if
so how you know what it it I don't know
if I would describe it as freedom but
the in a way that the truth that III
didn't have a lot to work with did set
me free very early on I had to face the
facts I was not gonna be able to get
everything I wanted or felt like I
needed for this project so I had to do
like a Jedi mind trick on myself and say
every obstacle that comes up because
there's there's 40 a day every obstacle
that comes up is a gift this is my
improv training working every every time
a brick wall gets put up that is putting
me in a position where I have an
opportunity to make a stronger choice
than I started with so this that is a
gift that that that knowledge that
wisdom of how to attack a film is a gift
I'll take with me for every project for
the rest of my life hey Jordan over here
on okay last one
when you going through this whole award
season I have to wonder it's kind of
crazy it's kind of surreal has it
inspired you in any way any kicked up
any stories in your head about maybe
future stuff that you want to do any
inspiration that way yeah I mean now
I've also often joked that the if
there's a get out to it will take place
an award show
where you know it might look something
like this I don't know no you know I the
what's been the most beautiful part
about this for me are all the full
circle moments of meeting heroes gary
oldman is coming out next i believe he
has been my favorite actor since Bram
Stoker's Dracula and and true romance I
got to sit down with him outside and we
just talked about this experience and we
we shot this and it's moments like that
it's moments like getting to meet Spike
Lee Steven Spielberg I got to meet
Francis Ford Coppola all my fellow
nominees these these are moments that
are priceless priceless priceless
priceless and I'll take them with me
forever
thank you graduations
[Applause]
you